in cucina con Favij nuovo programma
televisivo oggi Vi insegnerò a cucinare
Salmon Stake and boels questo è l'ordine
che mi è arrivato alla cucina cuciniamo
insieme ragazzi il salmone Nel caso non
sapesse sta in frigo prendiamo
Innanzitutto il salmone facciamo
moltissima attenzione
no ecco questa non è una ehm un taglio
Vabbè si riempie la pentola di acqua e
dopodiché andiamo a prendere le patate
se facciamo canestro da lontano il
piatto è ancora migliore vediamo
Perfetto allora il piatto non uscirà
benissimo OK c'ho Inside de acqua
prendiamo una da terra di quella che
abbiamo lasciato prima e mettiamo pure
questo perfetto bollite le patate si
prende la pentola E delicatamente si
scola piano Let's go 1 i dos
No piano no no aspetta che no solo sul
filetto questo 1 2 3 4 5 e il piatto è
pronto Buon appetito per altre ricette
Seguite la mia pagina Grazie